döner kebab grill fleisch vom spieß ins
laden brot mit einer salatmischung
grundsätze ein beliebter imbiss auf der
ganzen welt vor allem in deutschland
fest steht döner kebab ist türkisch für
sich drehendes grillfleisch spurensuche
in istanbul in der türkischen metropole
wird der döner meist so observiert hier
ist döner kebab anders als in
deutschland kein günstiger imbiss der
norwegische food blogger wie der bergung
lebt seit 2005 10 hier und befasst sich
schon länger mit der geschichte des
traditionellen duhner tellers kleber war
klassischerweise ein gericht dass man
ihm setzen lässt so wie es gerade vor
mir steht auf reis mit etwas gegrilltem
gemüse der döner kebab hat seinen
ursprung vor einigen jahrhunderten als
gegrilltes fleisch am spieß und tauchte
an verschiedenen orten in der türkei auf
in der türkei ist das fleisch der
hauptdarsteller beim döner weder soße
noch salat sollen seinen geschmack
verfälschen
grillmeister idris patzak betrachtet die
deutsche art der zubereitung skeptisch
für uns ist das seltsam rotes fleisch
passt nicht zu rotkohl kartoffeln
tomaten zwiebeln und paprika passen viel
besser zu einem döner kebab ein brot wir
haben noch nie gut gut verwendet das
hochwertige fleisch vom kalb und lamm
wird aber auch in der türkei nicht nur
auf dem teller serviert döner kebab gibt
es auch hier als fastfood zum mitnehmen
allerdings nicht genauso wie in
deutschland
irgendjemand hat die art von döner
erfunden die so allgegenwärtig in der
westlichen welt geworden ist und zwar in
brot gefüllt mit vielen verschiedenen
salaten und soßen
das wurde in deutschland erfunden
womöglich von berlin
er servierte den vielleicht ersten döner
deutschlands 1969 bei einem straßenfest
in der süddeutschen stadt reutlingen
ich stand war hier ich weiß sie hier
nämlich auch was sind auch viele leute
sind gestanden hier
hier haben wir auch geschnitten ich bin
sicher dass ich den döner macht stand
gebracht hat die diskussion als pro 50
jahre patentiert sie haben uns gefragt
was ist dass sie haben gedacht die
scheidende leberkäse oder sogar ich bin
sehr stolz dass ich ein stück
so hat er damals den döner spieß
geschichte aus rind- und lammfleisch
[Musik]
das fleisch schneidet er immer mit dem
messer fladenbrot gab es damals nicht in
reutlingen daher fühlt er einfach
schwäbische brötchen mit joghurt fleisch
petersilien zwiebeln tomaten fertig war
der wohl erste döner deutschlands doch
auch berlin gilt als geburtsort der
bereits verstorbene kann dir nur mann
soll in einer imbissbude am bahnhof zu
anfang der 70er jahre den döner deutsche
art erfunden haben mehr als 1000 döner
buden gibt es heute in der deutschen
hauptstadt von einfach bis edel im
zentrum berlins entwickelt denise
buchholz immer neue döner varianten zb
mit mango und anderen ungewöhnlichen
zutaten ein deutsch türkisches gericht
ein zeichen ihrer multikulturellen
freundschaft also wir fangen hat beim
anatolischen die scanner kebab an bis
hin zum gentrifiziert in berlin-mitte
döner mit trüffel und spargel dazu
bisschen fancy bisschen versaut aber
trotzdem auch was gutes für die seele
döner kebab eine türkisch-deutsche
erfolgsgeschichte